saying you can walk into a room and be
attend to somebody in that room but go
up to the wrong guy I mean not really
okay let's do it let's do a different
video
is lizzo gonna be a ton anywhere
close though as she goes to Japan that's
exactly what I'm that's exactly what I'm
saying no no but she's not gonna be a 10
anywhere I mean we could argue that
maybe like you know well yeah she could
be a 10 somewhere like I said in the
hood
just like every woman they have they
could be the exact perfect package for
the perfect person right but that's
exactly what I'm trying to say lizzo if
you want to use her as an example she's
a beautiful person on earth right right
I think what she's getting out of every
single person on Earth